- LET'S TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING IMPORTANT.
PUT THAT COFFEE DOWN.
DO YOU THINK
I'M [bleep] WITH YOU?
I AM NOT [bleep] WITH YOU.
YOU CALL YOURSELF A RANGER,
YOU SON OF A BITCH?
- I PEED.
- YOU ARE THE SORRIEST EXCUSE
FOR RANGERS I'VE EVER SEEN,
AND I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS
FOR 15 YEARS.
- WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
- [bleep] YOU.
THAT'S MY NAME.
- IS THAT KOREAN?
- BRICKLEBERRY IS THE WORST PARK
IN THE COUNTRY.
[bleep] AUSCHWITZ WOULD GET
A BETTER YELP REVIEW.
I'M HERE TO TURN
THIS DUMP AROUND,
AND I'M NOT LEAVING
UNTIL I DO.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE CHANGES.
NUMBER ONE: DRUG TESTS.
- IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE
WORKING HERE.
I'M GONNA MISS ALL OF Y'ALL.
BYE-BYE.
- THAT BRINGS US
TO WOODY JOHNSON.
YOU COULDN'T MANAGE A BLOW JOB
IN A DICK FACTORY.
- DICK FACTORY?
IS THAT WHERE THEY MAKE DICKS,
OR IS IT A FACTORY
MADE OUT OF DICKS?
- SHUT UP, YOU IDIOT!
I SHOULD FIRE YOUR FAT ASS.
- NO! PLEASE GIVE ME
ANOTHER CHANCE.
I KNOW THIS PARK SUCKS,
BUT I'LL HAVE A PLAN
TO FIX EVERYTHING
FIRST THING
IN THE MORNING.
- ALL RIGHT, JOHNSON,
BUT IT BETTER BE GOOD
OR THERE'LL BE HELL TO PAY.
- BYE, [bleep] YOU.